you are of course an analyst now on
inside the NBA on TNT and I know
everyone here at Turner so excited that
you're doing this this is a big deal for
us you're gonna be working with your old
friend Charles Barkley excited about
that he's a great guy he's a funny guy
you know we've got gotten into it many
times yeah but he's a great guy you know
he's gonna make people laugh and make
people laugh and hopefully it'll be a
great show just like your show that's so
nice of you to say thank you that was
the part where you inspire now okay I'm
curious about something you this show
has been around for a while inside the
NBA has established and they are quite
honest they give their honest opinions
about players and how they're playing as
a player have you ever watched that show
and had your feelings hurt or had your
feelings hurt by any analyst who said
something and you're sitting there
watching it they're talking about you or
been enraged smash a few TVs yeah you
know the only time I get upset is when
when analysts don't have the extensive
resume what do you mean just you mean
like oh if the analyst is an actually a
former player yeah but if you only got a
thousand points and no rings and no
all-star appearances and just flat-out
couldn't play
yeah you're making the same face you
made to the guard any names you want to
name here yeah okay but when you think
someone doesn't match up to your record
and they're criticizing you interesting
interesting stupidest
a choice the way he was hammering you
[Applause]
nothing I could do
come on in had me in a corner well
anyway let's move on skip bayless was
now I want to do something nice for you
because you know you've joined the
Turner family it's a huge deal as I said
us we're all so excited and you
mentioned the top the show that one of
your favorite things to do is ride
something it's way too small for you and
I thought what better way to go out to
commercial than to do that right now can
we get that out here fellas we bring
here we go would you join me please
[Applause]
which one which one do you want or did
you you want the pink cheap what's the
pink cheap okay
all right this is a green show so we're
not gonna use any gas we're gonna pull
these with ropes
[Applause]
I got it
you sure you're all right start your
engines let's go go yes
[Applause]